you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
how dozens of factories in southwest
detroit
are poisoning the air in what locals
call michigan's most polluted
zip code relentless climate change as
global temperatures
tick up un experts warn 2020 was one of
the three
warmest years on record
[Applause]
and wake up and smell the climate
resilient coffee
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and we aim to take you to the
heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come
we start today with what residents are
calling michigan's most
toxic zip code it's in a corner of
southwest detroit
where locals have spent years fighting
the quality of the air that they're
breathing in
in and around the 48217 district
there are more than 20 pollutant
producing facilities
owned by multiple companies and they
include an oil refinery
a steel mill and a coal-fired power
plant
residents say the pollutants in the air
have had major impacts on their health
and that of their children our u.s
correspondent cordelia lynch reports now
on what's been branded michigan's most
polluted area
[Applause]
this is the 48217 district
it became known as michigan's most
polluted postcode
residents around this corner of
southwest detroit
say their health has suffered because of
hazardous air pollutants
i was born prematurely i weighed three
pounds
and literally was born with asthma i'm
the only
cancer survivor still alive on the
street that i grew up on
i am a recipient of asthma
more than two dozen pollutant producing
facilities owned by multiple companies
are scattered across this area vicki
dobbins
says she's been feeling the weight of
industry in nearby river rouge
most of her life the people begin to ask
the question
what's going on what's in the smoke then
they start telling us
so2 co2 what's that mean
those are the things those are the
poisons and the pollutants
that are floating around in the air that
are killing your grass
because not only are you killing the
trees you're also killing people
tens of thousands of black people fled
segregation in the south
to live near here drawn to the booming
auto industry in detroit
teresa landrum said it was a utopia
but not anymore african americans
have been put into or forced to live in
areas that are polluted so environmental
racism has a lot to
do with where we live and where these
factories
and these industries are located
marathon the company which runs this
huge oil refinery
has offered to buy up homes to create a
buffer zone
it says it's reduced emissions by 80
over 20 years and now produces less than
three percent in a two mile radius
local activists though insist it all
adds up
[Music]
and rhonda anderson another cancer
survivor
wants radical change the demand would be
to shut down
all the fossil fuel places all of them
they don't need to be operating the
first thing that's going to do
is help those new babies you know
because right now
our babies are doomed
before they reach kindergarten
this isn't about one firm or one place
there's toxic air lead poisoning and
water shutoffs
across america big business and
government are under more pressure than
ever before
they've got a long way to go cordelia
lynch
sky news and cordelia also spoke to
renowned environmental campaigner erin
brockovich about michigan's most
polluted
zip code and you can see that interview
here on the daily climate show
tomorrow let's take a look now at some
of the day's other climate news
and it might be impossible to keep
global temperature rises
under 2 degrees above pre-industrial
levels
if the cop 26 summit that's due to be
held in glasgow
fails that's the conclusion from a group
of mps who say the climate summit needs
to be focused on the targets for success
well before it actually happens in
november tom
tugan hart is the chair of the foreign
affairs committee who released the
report
some of the things that we need to think
about is whether or not
you know how we count the carbon output
of an item whether we count it
tied to the uk as it was manufactured
here even though it was manufactured in
somewhere where
carbon emissions are more liberally
interpreted
[Applause]
the cost of financing renewable energy
projects is four times less than
investing in coal
a new study from the university of
oxford has found that the risk of
lending for new fossil fuel initiatives
has increased as the world moves to
cleaner energy sources
the most sustainable olympics was more
than 18 years ago in 2002.
the salt lake city games scored highest
in an analysis published today in nature
magazine
and has declined ever since researchers
measured how well each city performed in
economic
social and ecological sustainability the
report recommends
rotating between existing venues and
host cities
as well as reducing the number of
in-person spectators
[Applause]
one of the most common industrial
fishing methods could be releasing
millions of tons of carbon stored in the
seabed
the marine conservation society has
warned that bottom trawling where a
weighted net is pulled along the sea
floor to catch fish can damage the uk's
most vulnerable
sea habitats polling commissioned by
greenpeace
says that two-thirds of people now back
a ban on bottom trawling in marine
protected areas
and the world's most powerful tidal
turbine is beginning its journey to be
installed off the coast of scotland
the orbital o2 turbine will have the
capacity to generate electricity for
2 000 homes a year once it arrives at
the european marine energy center
in the waters of orkney now let's take
you over to our data dashboard now
and show you this number here now this
shows how much
human activity has warmed our planet
since the industrial revolution and it's
ticking up every single second
the aim agreed by 196 parties in 2015
as part of the paris agreement is to
keep that under two degrees preferably
to 1.5 degrees of warming and a crucial
report from the united nations has been
released today which found that in 2020
the global average temperature was about
1.2 degrees celsius
above pre-industrial levels so the state
of the global climate report
sets out how climate change indicators
and impacts
worsened around the world last year and
it found that
2020 was one of the three warmest years
on record
that's despite a cooling la nina event
now although lockdowns temporarily
reduce greenhouse gas emissions
overall atmospheric concentrations of
gases such as carbon dioxide and methane
continue to rise more than four-fifths
of seas
experienced at least one marine heat
wave last year
and there were record high temperatures
in the arctic circle in siberia and
arctic
sea ice shrank to its second lowest
summer minimum
on record well let's bring in our
climate change correspondent lisa
holland now and lisa not all of these
findings are new so what's the
significance of this
significance of this report being
released now well anna i think the
significance is in its timing in that it
comes just a couple of days before this
crucial virtual summit which is being
hosted
by the united states when america will
implore
other countries to up their ambitions to
reduce greenhouse gases
now this conference which will come up
towards the end of the week is seen as
really pivotal
and this report helps underline just how
critical
the situation is not just with some of
the data which we already knew about
just how
warm the planet has got but with some of
the really stark language which is being
used
by the world meteorological organization
and the united nations talking about
the relentlessness of climate change
it's a pretty
stark message and really clearly they
are
trying to tell the world that there is
no time to waste
lisa thank you
a coffee species has been rediscovered
in the wild that could help
future-proof the global coffee supply
against the effects of climate change
the rare and little-known species from
west africa has
a similar flavor profile to high-quality
arabica coffee
but with greater tolerance for higher
temperatures and rainfall variability
well joining me now is the head of
coffee research at royal botanic gardens
q dr aaron davis dr davis thanks so much
for talking to us and you've been
studying this species of coffee
so talk us through what properties it
has that makes it more resilient to
climate change
yeah i as you said it has two really key
uh characteristics uh first is that it's
able to withstand um very high
temperatures compared to other coffee
species and particularly arabica coffee
so it will grow in temperatures many
degrees above
arabica and a few degrees above robusta
so that's important
in terms of climate resilience um but
on the other on the other side things it
has an amazing taste and if we look at
all the other coffee species of which
there are 124
none have this unique combination
so how vulnerable to climate change is
coffee more generally and what could
this mean
for some of those farmers in areas most
affected by rising temperatures
so uh coffee um the coffee sector is
increasingly vulnerable to climate
change and it's seen as one of the major
threats to the sector particularly going
across this century
and that will impact the 100 or
100 million or so coffee farmers
worldwide
and the hope is that initially this will
be used
as a crop for some of those farmers
particularly in africa
and the long-term aspiration is that
will be used to breed
the next generation of coffee crops will
that will be
you know resilient at least to
two or three degrees rising in
temperature
and this species has only recently been
rediscovered hasn't it so
how rare is it and are there concerns
about safeguarding it
yes there are it is a rare species it's
threatened with extinction in the wild
due to deforestation
and you know we have to do our utmost to
to preserve
not only this species but other species
that may have potential for
securing the long-term sustainability of
this detector
and you said earlier that it tasted
really good are you able to describe the
taste at all
yeah i am it's it's absolutely
fantastic we we had very low
expectations
um based on our other experiences of
wild coffee but this has a natural
sweetness
it has a great complexity of uh in its
flavour profile
it's everything you'd expect in a great
cup of coffee very well done it's not
easy to explain a taste dr aaron davis
thanks very much indeed
that's everything from us for today on
the daily climate show tomorrow our
correspondent cordelia lynch speaks to
environmental activist erin brockovich
whose successful lawsuit against the
pacific gas and electric company
was turned into a hollywood hit starring
julia roberts
i am aaron brockovich and i am delighted
to be here with you at sky news today
and i have to give you a shout out
because i am damn proud of you
taking on the conversation of climate of
water of this planet of its future
putting it out there so people know
so people can learn that's at the same
time tomorrow here on sky news
see you then
you